rolling hey guys i'm abby Sharpe welcome
to Abby's kitchen since you all enjoyed
my what I eat in a day videos so much I
thought I would share with you my
morning routine now that the wedding is
over
so I partnered up with Zespri and Vichy
to share with you this kind of behind
the scenes action of what I do every
single morning so let's take a look okay
so I'm usually a pretty good morning
person but it's getting darker and
darker outside so it's like so much
harder to get up in the morning honestly
so I'm really strict about having you
know nice skin so I like to wash my face
thoroughly before I go out and have a
big sweat sesh at the gym so I was
really excited to partner with Vichy for
this video because they've got this
awesome skin line that is perfect for
committing breakouts but still making
sure that it's nice and gentle on my
sensitive skin so my general routine is
I like to give my face a good wash with
the Vichy Normandy cleansing gel and
then I use the purifying pore tightening
lotion just to make sure I'm starting
things off with a nice clean slate so I
like to set my clothes out the night
before so that way I can kind of just
get up and get out of here
so when I work out really early in the
morning usually
time for like a full-on breakfast and I
probably wouldn't want to anyway I think
it was like slow me down so I just
usually grab up a quick piece of fruit
and these Zespri thunderbolt kini fruit
have become my go-to because there's
about hundred calories in two of them
you've got some fiber in there lots of
antioxidants and as much potassium as
banana okay guys so now I've got some
energy to go meet my trainer so I'm
usually really busy on the weekdays so I
like to have my breakfast all ready to
go so check out these easy tropical
baked oatmeal cups that I made last
weekend in a bowl unmixed together at
the oats coconut cashews baking powder
ginger and salt in another bowl I mixed
together at the mashed banana coconut
milk eggs vanilla coconut oil diced
Zespri sungold kiwi fruit and pineapple
I combined the wet ingredients with the
dry ingredients and I let the batter sit
for about ten minutes then I divide the
batter between each of the muffin tins
smooth out the surface and then top each
with a slice of zesty green kiwi fruit
bake them for about 20 to 25 minutes or
until you see a like golden-brown color
form around the edges then allow them to
cool for at least 30 minutes before
removing them carefully from the tin
enjoy immediately or pop them into a
freezer bag and freeze for later so I
usually just pull a few out of the
freezer when I'm kind of hungry for
breakfast pop it in the microwave till
they warm up and I'm ready to eat so I'm
gonna be working from home today and I
definitely need a little coffee to get
this party started so I'm gonna make a
quick latte with some milk
okay guys so now I'm gonna go where you
can't follow me so
so I really do try to take the time to
sit down for all of my meals so that way
I can actually mindfully enjoy each bite
all right guys now it's time to get to
work
so this is around the time that I really
need a snack so I'm gonna portion out a
little chia pudding and top it off with
a little bit of fruit
okay guys so it's pretty much noon which
means I get to sign off and get a little
privacy here I've got some videos to
edit and some blog posts right so I'm
gonna get back to work so guys I hope
you enjoyed my little morning routine
thank you so much to be she and d'esprit
for collaborating with me on this video
if you liked what you saw be sure to
give it a thumbs up subscribe to the
channel and leave me a comment below I
would love to hear what some of your
favorite go to breakfast are and I will
try to make them a little healthier
faster and easier for those weekday
mornings thanks again guys see you next
time on Abby's kitchen
you